guys it turns out you don't have to
spend a lot of money to make your suit
look way better
I'm GQ solid inner wheel well GQ suit
expert John teeths we're going to show
you four little things you can do to
make your suit look way better for under
100 bucks what's nice about a waist
extension tab is that you don't need to
worry about it's clean it's modern it's
a minimal normal waist waist extension
tab should we compare crotches here I
actually have a waist extension tab [ __ ]
I didn't know that alright the sort of
new piece of news here is that even
really affordable suited brands are
doing these things right exactly
everyone from Topman j.crew to zenia's
in the world so guys this is something
that doesn't have to cost you anything
it's just something you look for a
little tailor detail when you're buying
a new suit number two put a cup on your
pants very cheap but a very nice
tailored detail BAM
all right guys for 15 to 20 bucks taking
a pair of pants have a tailor put a one
and a half inch cuff on there and
suddenly you're seated style is just
starting to crank up John I got to say
number three is a bit of a surprising
one to me you're saying the new thing is
your tie should match your jacket but
we're not talking about matching
patterns here we're already talking
about color matching to add a little bit
of contrast I went slightly darker with
my tie right and I put it with a graft
check shirt to keep it nice and clean
but still pop with a little bit of
character BAM
alright guys John said it and John's
wearing it it looks great match your tie
to your suit jacket a shocker to me but
hey here's the proof and number four get
a new pocket square right yeah the
bandanna is great we still love it but
we also are really embracing the fool
arts
it's that retro kind of throwback feel
but it gives you a little bit of
attitude John when you say foulard are
you speaking French to me yes don't be
worried to like do pops of color - we
got the turquoises the Greens the Reds
the Blues guys you don't have to worry
too much about how to fold a pocket
square even with like tags hanging off
it and stuff you just fold it up cram it
down in there John my falar dude if we
let in alright sweet alright guys that's
it thanks for watching if you got any
style questions for GQ leave them in the
comments mr. John teats thank you sir
well what low-five